the british government now wants us to
now
deny us the chance for justice by
introducing an amnesty for these murders
i want to speak directly to the people
of britain
at this moment
can you imagine what would happen if the
soldiers murdered 10
unarmed civilians on the streets of
london
liverpool or birmingham what would you
expect an investigation
would you expect justice or would you be
happy for them to get a namaste
i don't think so the mod spin doctors
just
like they said 50 years ago are
circulating the lies
they're describing these investigations
are facetious
or unfair prosecutions the police have
never
to this day investigated the deaths of
our loved ones
no one should be above the law we will
not accept an amnesty
for for these murders omni is there for
people honestly
amnesties are for people who are free
out of the truth
if the british government are so proud
of their legal system
why did not trust it instead
they chose to ignore then
internationally recognize agreements
be it made up by their own laws and they
make their own laws when it suits them
every victim should have their right to
pursue justice
one name i didn't read it earlier
was patty mccarthy
the eleventh victim the paulo murphy
musker party was beaten
he's brutalized soldiers of one power
then pretended that they were going to
kill him
and the shadow was here this was too
much for a pure party
and he suffered a heart attack and died
our thoughts about paddy's family i know
they are with us today
and i want to say to him we will never
give up on the suit for truth for party
our thoughts are also with those who
died on the long extreme
difficult journey
the many members who died prematurely as
a direct
of the result losing a loved one
the witness who spoke truth to power and
had the courage to make the statements
and the campaigners mr
the campaigners who stood above her
shoulders shoulder
and self-die on our journey we remember
them a day
and love and fullness and may they rest
in peace
so what's next for our campaign today
the verdicts
will take us for for our new process
the murphy massacre families and console
lords
over the past 50 years we are determined
that we now focus should firm we are
determined that
now the focus should firmly on on those
who cause the deaths of our loved ones
and also the innocence of our loved ones
the inquest were haran thinkers were
high on our deal
we heard horrific evidence about our
loved ones
no one should ever hear we need to come
we need time to process recover
recoup in the weeks ahead and only then
will we consider what our next steps are
i want to thank the coroner
and our staff for all the hard work and
professionalism
throughout the inquest i also want to
thank our legal teams
for their dedication we will never
forget how you continually went above
and beyond to help
our pursuit for truth the most important
thing
for us today our loved ones
are declared innocent they were unjustly
finally
murdered 30 years ago thanks very much